Things look bleak for Tony Stark in the Avengers:
Endgame trailer, but Iron Man has been in
some pretty tight squeezes before.
Endgame's cast includes spacefarers, gods,
wizards, interstellar warlords, and more.
In all likelihood, Stark's rescue isn't a
question of if, but of who and when.
Tony spends the Avengers: Endgame trailer
leaving a final message for his one true love,
Pepper Potts.
So it's only fitting that it will probably
be Pepper who saves him.
Not only would it be an emotionally satisfying
payoff, it also makes sense.
Pepper was talking to Tony when he left Earth,
so she knows where to start the search.
As the CEO of Stark Industries, she has the
resources to mount a rescue, and as Tony's
fiancee, she certainly has the motive.
Plus, we've seen her rescue him before, in
Iron Man 3.
Perhaps the biggest clue, though, is the fact
that leaks from the set of Avengers: Endgame
suggested that Pepper would be donning her
own suit of armor for the film.
That's something she's done in the comics,
where her superhero codename is…
Rescue.
"Just for the record, being adrift in space
with zero promise of rescue is more fun than
it sounds."
Yeah, it seems pretty obvious when we put
it that way!
When Thanos snapped his fingers and caused
the Decimation, the only two warriors on distant
Titan left alive were Tony Stark and Nebula.
It's unclear whether Nebula is on the ship
with Tony in the Endgame trailer.
But it would make sense if she ended up saving
Tony.
After all, she has plenty of experience flying
these super advanced spacecraft, plus she
may be able to use her status as a cyborg
to help repair the ship.
We know she will want revenge on Thanos for
the death of Gamora, and saving Tony may just
help her get it.
After the heartbreaking loss of Groot at the
end of Avengers: Infinity War, Rocket was
essentially left alone on Earth.
It would make sense if he left to find out
the fate of the rest of his Guardians of the
Galaxy family.
Unfortunately, they were all snapped out of
existence back on Titan, but if Rocket goes
searching for them, he could very well find
Tony instead.
Thor and Tony Stark aren't best friends, but
they are both founding Avengers, and the Odinson
isn't going to leave Stark hanging if he can
help it.
Thanks to his new hammer Stormbreaker, Thor
seems to be able to access the Bifrost and
teleport vast distances across space.
If he goes looking for Stark - perhaps with
the help of his new sidekick Rocket - Stormbreaker
could help him get there in the nick of time.
Tony isn't the only refugee set adrift in
space due to the evil of Thanos.
There's also half of the Asgardians who were
attacked at the end of Thor: Ragnarok.
Endgame director Joe Russo has said that Valkyrie
survived the attack, and fans certainly hope
that scene-stealing favorite Korg also survived.
It would be fitting, and thrilling, if Valkyrie
and Korg showed up in the nick of time to
rescue Tony.
After Wong saved Tony from certain death in
Avengers: Infinity War, the two became instant
best buds.
"Wong, you're invited to my wedding!"
So can Wong do it again?
In Infinity War, Doctor Strange seems pretty
nervous about Stark's ability to get them
back to Earth, implying that he couldn't do
it with magic.
But why not?
If wizards can step between dimensions, why
not between planets?
Sure, they need to visualize their destination,
but if Tony is able to get a video SOS back
to Earth, maybe Wong can open a portal with
his sling ring and get them both back to the
church in time.
Captain Marvel was nowhere to be seen in the
Avengers: Endgame trailer, but thanks to the
Avengers: Infinity War post-credits teaser,
we know she'll be an important part of Endgame.
And we know from the Captain Marvel trailer
that she can soar through the spaceways under
her own power.
What better way to introduce her to the Avengers
than by having her save Tony Stark?
Things look pretty dire for Tony in the Endgame
trailer.
But things have looked pretty bad for him
before, and he's managed to work miracles
with far less.
"Tony Stark was able to build this in a cave!
With a box of scraps!"
So it would be no surprise if Tony suddenly
got a flash of brilliance that allowed him
to save himself.
After losing everything in the fight against
Thanos, it seems as though his confidence
is at an all time low.
But maybe his love for Pepper will be enough
to shake him out of his stupor so he can fix
his spaceship and get home in once piece.
The shockingly bleak end of Avengers: Infinity
War had many fans in tears.
But what if Marvel saved the worst blow for
last?
Maybe what we see in this trailer is exactly
what we're going to get: Tony, alone in space,
drifting off into oblivion, never to be seen
again.
Would it be disappointing?
Yes.
Devastating?
Sure.
But is it likely?
Well, probably not.
But after the way they killed off poor Peter
Parker, we wouldn't put anything past those
monsters.
"I'm sorry!"